foreign
[Music]
ization
query data safe and secure means sharing
access only with authorized users
in this video you will learn how to use
identity and access management or IAM to
provide fine-grained Access Control to
users including which permissions are
necessary to access data in tables and
to run queries within a project
you'll also learn how to troubleshoot
and result some common permission errors
in bigquery
using iam you can grind individual
permissions or abundance of permissions
called roles to a user let's take a look
at some common bigquery tasks and which
permissions they require
First Step ask them the query table data
this action requires the bigquery tables
get data permission
the bigquery data viewer IE hemroid has
this permission and provides the ability
to read data and metadata
you can kind this role at a table or
view level at a data set level to
Encompass all tables within the data set
or at the organization of project levels
Next Step running queries requires the
bigquery jobs create permission this
permission allows you to create and run
jobs including queries and in turn have
them build to that project's billing
account
the predefined IAM Royal bigquery job
user has this permission and is granted
at a project level
there are a few important things to
remember
a dataset and its underlying tables do
not need to be in the same project where
the query is being run
that is if a user has the bigquery data
viewer role for a specific data set or
table then that user can run query jobs
for that data from any project in which
they have the bigquery shop user on
resources in Google Cloud are organized
hierarchically in the following order
organizations projects data sets and
then tables resources inherit the allow
policies of the parent resource
granting a royal to the user at a
specific level will provide the
permissions of that role at all levels
lower than that level
for example granting the bigquery data
viewer I enrolled at a project level
will provide the permissions of this
role to this user for all data sets and
tables in a specific approach
keep your data secure use the principle
of least privilege
Grant the most limited predefined or
custom role with bare minimum
permissions necessary for the user to
perform their job
now let's troubleshoot and resolve some
common permission errors encountered
while accessing bigquery tables in this
first scenario I'll try to query data
from a bigquery table
I am going to open a cloud shell session
and execute the following BQ command to
query data from the table Shakespeare in
the public data set samples
this error indicates that the user does
not have bigquery jobs create permission
required to create the bigquery job in
the specific project
to investigate this issue the first step
is to determine which user is trying to
execute the job which we can do in Cloud
login
we can go there directly by searching
for logs Explorer
we'll set the time interval to the
specific duration when we observe the
error for this case I'll set as the last
15 minutes as we just encounter the
error next we'll use this filter to
search the past errors related to
creating bigquery jobs
this looks to be the one that we are
looking for
we can expand the fields and narrow it
down to the authentication info
principle email field there you go this
is the user which has insufficient
permissions
the result of this issue will go to the
IAM page here we can grant the user the
bigquery job user IM role which has the
required permissions to create bigquery
jobs
I'll execute the bigquery command again
and now we can see that it completes and
we get the query results
let's now jump into the next scenario
where I'll try to access the query table
maintained in a different project I'll
start a cloud shell session which is
configured to use the project bigquery
project 7.
this time and execute the BQ command to
create a bigquery job with a querying
table data that resides in the project
PQ data sets 3000
oh I see a new error
this error indicates that the user
doesn't have the permissions to access
the data in the table in Project BQ that
is 2000 similar to the previous scenario
we can determine the user trying to
execute this job by heading to Cloud
login from project bigquery project 7.
there you go
this is the user which has insufficient
permissions to the table in Project PQ
that is its 3000 recall from our
discussion on bigquery IM prerequisites
you must have the bigquery data viewer I
enrolled to query data in the bigquery
tables
you can resolve this issue by granting
the bigquery data viewer IAM role to the
user and project BQ datasets 3000 at a
project data set at table level
I'll do this at a table level
in the project containing the table
let's go to bigquery SQL workspace page
navigate to the table that a query is
trying to access click on share and
Grant the user with bigquery data viewer
IM role which has the required
permissions to access and query this
table
not that when granting data set table a
view level access you will do so from
the bigquery console rather than the IAA
page
now let's try to execute the PQ command
again
and it completes the permission error is
resolved and we as the user are returned
the query results
for learning more about bigquery access
controls please check out this
documentation
thanks for watching
[Music]